mais d'abord ils ont enfin rechausser
les crampons ou enfourché leur vélo un
mois après l'arrêt des activités pour
cause de kovy 19è les enfants ont pu
retourner sur les terrains de sport
uniquement en extérieur pour l'instant
moyennant quelques précautions
sanitaires c'était aujourd'hui le grand
défouloir tant attendu le reportage de
romain delville au club de bmx de
saint-avertin sur la piste de label'vie
le bmx pour les petits c'est reparti
donc là on y retourne on passe d'un art
lit on prend l'air ni vire à l'envers on
continue on tombe sur la même base entre
les vacances de la toussaint le
confinement d'automne ça fait plus d'un
mois et demi que les jeunes n'ont pas
pratiqué en club ou à plus d'un
kilomètre de chez eux
aujourd'hui c'est le bonheur retrouvé de
pédaler et de revoir les copains du bmx
ça fait longtemps aussi qu'on en n'a pas
fait ça nous motive sur les bosses ça
fait un peu bizarre parfois dépasser ces
mêmes sensations mais c'est une bourre
encore mieux parce qu'on n'avait pas
fait depuis longtemps la fin de la
saison dernière a été tronqué le début
de la saison 2020-2021 joue
l'intermittence elie l'entraîneur doit
s'adapter
c'est comme un peu en retour de blessure
comment par retour de blessure on a fait
ce top pendant à peu près un mois ou
deux mois et après le retour pour les
parents et grands parents présents à
l'entraînement
le cours de sport des petits a des airs
de déconfinement un besoin vital de
liberté et de dépenses énergétiques
était très important pour je pense tous
nos enfants de reprendre une activité
physique aussi bien pour leur équilibre
physique que mental c'était vraiment un
besoin
prochaine étape le 15 décembre
alors les jeunes sportifs et les jeunes
sportives pourront jouer à l'intérieur
c'est le gouvernement veut bien